stéphane rozès on était sur la
communication présidentielle et
gouvernementale on en a entendu tout à
l'heure au micro de david khalifa damien
abad parler de parodie de démocratie
pour le chef de file des républicains à
l'assemblée et puis françois ruffin le
député en somme il lui a parlé de
chambre d'enregistrement
c'est cela ou bien ce qui s'est passé ce
matin c'est un véritable échange par le
menteur oui absolument c'est un dialogue
de sourds ont font nos présidents en
dernière instance tranche c'est normal
mais sans qu'à aucun moment en amont la
représentation nationale a été bloquée
puisque les décisions se prennent à
l'intérieur d'un conseil le président
tranche en écoutant plus ou moins les
autorités sanitaires et en outre au
sommet de l'état on le sait depuis y
avoir des différences d'approché entre
d'un côté le comédie très de ministre de
la santé qui était sur l'île de beaucoup
plus hachée coûté les autorités
sanitaires de confiner plus rapidement
enfin de prendre des mesures plus
draconiennes et le président m'a conquis
pour des raisons économiques ou si un
psycho logique par rapport aux effets
des mesures salutaires étaient sur une
position qui puisse justement vous
parlez de respect sicot logique un
important aspect psychologique par
rapport à cette séquence de
communication notamment du président il
hier il a fixé un cap un calendrier une
carotte même si j'ai envie de dire c'est
la carotte de la mi mai mais on se
souvient début avril le premier début
mars le 1er mars exactement il avait dit
il faut tenir encore quatre à six
semaines ces terres près d'ailleurs par
gabriel attal son porte parole le porte
parole du gouvernement
enfin encore attendre deux semaines pour
aboutir aux six semaines qu'il avait
évoquée mais mais cette fois est ce
qu'on peut
dire qu'il va tenir sa promesse sa
promesse bien ce que c'est juste une
façon de rassurer les français
je pense que d'abord vous avez région en
termes de communication doit fixer un
moment butoir pour justifier des efforts
beaucoup des combles avec oak également
de l'ampleur de la campagne vaccinale à
cet égard le fbi vient de pointer
durement les grands attache européen et
datant du 17 millions si tout va bien de
vacciner à la mi juin
d'ailleurs au moment des régionales 40
millions en septembre et d'aldo pays se
sortent d'affaires par des campagnes de
vaccination beau tard east décidé de
façon souveraine au plan national par
leur gouvernance la france est en bas de
tableau et au fond dans tous les
domaines des mages des tests pour venir
à la vaccination que vous êtes en train
d'évoquer vacciner tous les jours de la
semaine et week-end et même les
ansériennes dixit à emmanuel macron hier
soir pourtant le vaccinodromes du stade
de france sera fermée le dimanche
quid encore là de la communication
présidentielle c'est à dire là encore il
faut la communication et aux services
aux difficultés le politique est au
service du réel
donc évidemment il ya une pression de
l'opinion française maintenant pour la
vaccination mais encore faut-il métiers
des vaccins encore faut-il qu on
s'approvisionne soit de façon volontaire
sur les bassins européens soit sur des
patins d'origine d'autres choses et que
les considérations sanitaires prime sur
les considérations géopolitiques je
pense aux russes aucune bayeux chinois
on a entendu tout à l'heure
jean castex à l'assemblée nationale
d'hier ni trop tôt ni trop tard
et puis d'un autre côté damien abad lui
a dénoncé le contretemps permanent qui a
raison qui a tort
bon d'abord soyons modestes
le président m'a on n'a pas eu tort de
garde ce n'était pas lui le maître des
horloges mecs étaient la pandémie les
observer qu'il a le réseau objectivement
luthor politiquement car dans un pays
comme la france le politique n'est pas
seulement variable d'adaptation donc le
sujet c'est plutôt que la stratégie
c'est à dire c'est pas tant la maîtrise
du temps que la capacité d'informer à
temps les français à partir des données
des mesures et on fonce
la difficulté plus grand de nos
gouvernants avec l'opinion publique
c'est cette difficulté là une
contradiction entre un intérieur vie
politique et dans la tradition et puis
une difficulté où aucun des instruments
et des outils ni ne semble être à la
hauteur les français ne sont pas des
enfants
ils comprennent puisse y avoir des
erreurs d'appréciation ne comprennent
pas qu'ils soient pas considérés comme
suffisamment adulte au pont kuss sans
cesse expliquer arié des décisions des
noms des fichiers
merci stéphane rozès d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue président de cap
et enseignant à hec et à sciences po
notamment